each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay okay so today we're very pleased to
have Dimitri Kovac Kovac who's a postdoc
in the cartography research group here
speaking to us on its work on
cryptanalysis of AES and shot - Pearson
good morning everyone I'm also very
pleased to have the opportunity to share
my views on the recent results on AES
enchi - where I participated as far as
you might know it made some industry
impacts a medium but but the theoretical
and practical consequences are quite
different from which you might expect
just looking at newspapers and Press
reports so I will talk today about
symmetric encryption and symmetric
primitive fashioned symmetric fashioned
and start with the talk about AES as a
block cipher and about chateaux as a
hash function so just small introduction
to the framework block cipher is a fixed
length encryption primitive which
encrypts data block by block and on the
very high level it's a permutation
parameterised by a key a key is secret
and generally the adversity goal when he
attacks a system using a block cipher is
to recover that key to being able to be
able to read the encrypted communication
and most of the attacks on block ciphers
are key recovery attacks at the most
natural target and the common framework
for key recovery texts and you are able
to use some data from the past some
pairs some plaintext and ciphertext
possibly be chosen by you and your
target is to recover a key and hence
being able to
the future communication as the key is
has fixed-length say and--but then an
attack is considered to whale it well
from theoretical point of view at least
if it recovers the key faster than just
the end trials because you can always
try all possible keys just one by one
and of course as n is quite large and in
molar cybers 128 and higher then a whale
attack is not necessary a practical
attack and attack you might be concerned
of for hash function sedation is what a
bit similar and both ability and a bit
different hash function compressed
service with one key inputs to fix land
queries and this typically iterative as
the hash function has no secret the
attacks on it and the compromising of a
system to use hash function is a bit
different and common the most
devastating attacks on hash functions
are those that find collisions which
means finding two different inputs which
yield the same hash value and an attack
by a premature tag which just stands for
the inversion of a hash function so find
in any pre image to this function
collision attacks generic collision
attacks run in two to the N over two and
and in the hash length so any collision
attack faster than two to the N over two
is again consider it a way that attack
and an attack a pre-image attack faster
than to two then there's also considered
evaluated again and in modern hash
function is quite large and the game
attacks whale it from theoretical point
of view are not necessarily be in any
particular attack and as you will see
most of the texts we are talking about
are not practical at all and my reports
even that in future they might not be so
let me continue with
my first topic yeah it's AES advanced
encryption standard I will try to talk
about AES and the hash standard chateau
in parallel try to show if they have
some similarities in the design or in
the attack vectors and in their security
so advanced encryption standard
abbreviated as AES was designed 15 years
ago by two Bilgin cryptographers and its
original name is just catenation of the
first letters of their last name strain
though so es has three versions for
different key sizes 128 192 and 256 and
has different number of rounds each
number is a weaker sub function which
has both non linear and linear elements
and two rounds of AES are depicted on
the right so here you see that each
round starts with an addition of a so
called sub key which is derived from the
original master key and then three
operations the same in every round
personal linear operation sub bytes and
then two linear operations
despite this simplicity the cells on a
picture are bite despite the simplicity
is proved itself to be a very tough
target for attackers and cryptanalyst
when selected as AES the best key
recovery attack was mounted on seven
rounds and it was only a short cut at X
which means that an advantage over just
brute force key recovery was quite small
so a small factor even not precisely
evaluated by the authors of the paper it
was sent on the rounds for AES 120 if
you see that seven is quite quite close
to ten so originally AAS 128 has ten
rounds and while seven was first close
to ten and some people said that it's
not a big security margin the time
proved that the security margin is
good enough as for years no attack on
eight rounds no key recovery attacks and
a truant appeared till the very last
year despite of well I am not
exaggerating so hundreds of papers were
written on the EAS cryptanalysis of
cover if counting also side channel
analysis of a es implementations so
really almost any personal who was doing
some Krypton also tried to break KS in
his experience so the design and the
competition for yes was public that was
sorry that was quite a contrast to
Chateau as Herr Schneider so it was
designed around 2000 and adopted as a
standard two years later it also has two
different well it has four versions but
we are mainly interested in to the most
important 256 hash value and 512-bit
hash value so the first one has 64
rounds the second valve has 80 and the
structure is quite different and
actually was inherited from earlier hash
function design well the thing is I'm
not sure how clear it is from the
picture but my impression is that shot
to looks much more messy than AES and
from many others point of view it's the
truth at NSA well when designed Chateau
didn't try to make some kind of
transparent design which was easy to
evade from public but just try to
involve as many strong operations as
they wanted which resulted in one one
hand quite a strong cash function on the
other hand their analysis was very
difficult and many people just didn't
try to start with the analysis of
Chateau and the number of papers or two
is much lower compared to ease and well
on the one on what 100 says it tells us
that Chateau is strong
because people couldn't find any
weakness on the other hand most of the
people who work in in decrypting
symmetric hypnosis will not be surprised
if something will be found in chat oh
yeah I think it is well if something
reasonable will be found today yes
people will be great surprised if
something will be found in shot - this
will not be so good - surprise because
shot - actually doesn't carry with
itself know kind of proofs for its
strength despite of numerous linear
nonlinear and tell the types of elements
appearing in its structure so chateau
had no public relations no attacks in
contrast three years what kind of a text
I'm talking about let me make a small
survey so the first attacks AES was
designed to counteract were so-called
statistical attacks the idea was to find
in a primitive a property which holds
with the reasonably high probability say
P and if you have this property for
example an input with property P or
Delta P is converted to transform to
ciphertext to output with property Delta
C if this holds for the reason we helper
builder than on one hand were able to
collect sufficiently many inputs outputs
with this property just making about one
over P encryptions on the other hand
each so-called right plain text after
text pair yield information about
internal variables as this property is
just kind of sequence of properties
throughout the cipher and as you know
that this property was halted different
eternal variables does it give you
information about this internal
variables so if you have some property
not just you measured something over
cipher but you claim that in the cipher
something happened here something
happened here something happened here
and just multiplicate the probability of
this events you get the property for the
full cipher and if you observe this kind
of property which means that indeed
would it's likely that this events
indeed appeared and this gives you
information about journal variables and
from the information of internal
internal where was to get information
about the key that
the main principle of statistical
attacks appears in the beginning of 90s
starting with attacks on des the feature
of differential finger Katinas was that
despite that I broke this theoretically
they didn't break it practical in the
sense that no one really wanted to if
someone has a goal to recover this key
he didn't implement nor of this method
well linear cryptanalysis most kind of
implemented so guys really collected to
the forty or something data and they
just try to recover the key and they
succeeded but so far if you are
interested in finding the DES key you
rather buy a dedicated hardware which is
less than ten thousand dollar cost and
teeth will recover a 56 bit key of this
without requiring all this tremendous
amounts of data so what is interesting
that despite this method superiors more
than twenty years ago so far there is no
good method which can recover this key
better than just brute force I mean
practically better for shot to City and
it's very safe situation is a bit bit
it's a bit different as I talked about
collision and premature resistance for
both share zero and sha-1 which are
similar to shuttle but simpler and
weaker collision attacks exist and turns
a zero there is a practical attack I
mean there are practical collisions
partial zero for sha-1 there is no
practical attack but there is
theoretical attack with complexity bowed
to the 61 which is just a bit behind the
computational power of normal research
unit that's why this collisions have
been never found although there there
there is a couple of project that tried
to find this kind of collisions and
there was no premature text on the full
version nor of zero nor on sha-1 so so
far succeed
pretty much attacks exist on their on
much weaker functions like md5 so when
I'm defied there is a not completely non
practical preimage attack but instead
zero and sha-1 there is no primatech on
the full version and the situation with
chateau is even worse ok that was my
quick introduction to es and Chateau and
this kind of hesitation with no attacks
on the full version existed till 2009
when well like in 2009 AES has existed
for about 10 years and really people
start to think that a yes is something
more than a good cipher so maybe yes as
a structure which takes just two inputs
plaintext and a key it can be a good
universal primitive even when you don't
care which is the plain text which is
the key you just have function which
compresses two input to one output and
it's for one input it's a kind of
permutation form tied by a second input
well people start to think that it can
serve as a universal premature though it
was never formally stated well this was
proved to be wrong so this is the
starting point where our attacks on AES
appeared oh you have any questions by
this point several days and it was
designed sort of kind of three four
years ago also I think with current high
regard designs can be even faster so the
first step towards showing some weakness
nAES worst occult related key attacks
which try to demonstrate that es is not
good as a universal primitive so they
didn't demonstrate that the AES is bad
as an encryption standard as this kind
of attacks required that a user is able
to observe and work on data encrypted on
two different but related keys and the
relation between the key is depicted
here is a and B is even chosen by the
adversary the relation was itself quite
complicated so it not just and a large
subset of relations which you can use
the relation was chosen following some
properties of AES and it was chosen so
that the difference so-called difference
and keys can be combined with this
difference in plaintext and this
relation and key can be canceled somehow
cancel the relation in the plaintext
that's why the date encrypted on two
keys was correlated in some sense I hope
that this correlation one is able to
recover either key that was the
framework and two attacks appeared on
the es the first attack didn't recover
anything it just demonstrated the
property of a fully es kind of strange
properties so suppose you can choose
several plaintext and several keys
different and each step but they have
the common property so if you select a
specific difference Delta key in the
keys then encryption of which plaintext
the difference of encryptions on say key
one and they changed key one on key to
and changed key to yields the same
ciphertext difference so you are able
for example it can be just nexor size of
suppose you have a cipher and you are
able to choose all these plaintiffs all
these keys single difference of in the
key and single difference in the
ciphertext how hard it is is it to
construct
this think it was proved that its heart
it's for a large queue it's close to two
to the M and the key size and it was
demonstrated that such construction can
be found on the PC for AES 256 which was
a large difference in complexity with
total 128 or 256 but it the material on
the some property of the full AES when
using different keys it didn't tell
anything about the security of a years
as a single key encryption scheme some
stronger attacks but also in the related
key model appeared half a year later it
indeed she recovered the key but it had
to observe data relay encrypted on four
different keys and the relation between
those keys was chosen in even more
complicated way and the complexity was
much higher so it was not possible to
recover a key on a PC anymore so it was
a theoretical result and it was
theoretical result in a weaker model so
despite this first science of weaknesses
in AES that was still weakness in quite
a weak setting in the relay and those
years nothing basically happened to shut
to so I proceed to the recent attacks on
AES which also found their applications
in chateau well her logical it was
opposite so the first first attacks on
shuttle were found and then we figured
out how to translated them to years past
attacks on AES got more attention so I
started with them it might be even
simpler to explain so there isn't text
and AES separate encircled with the
Scott meet-in-the-middle technique I aim
to explain you in the meeting window
technique in almost completely I hope
well I think that it's one of the
simplest technique to recover a key when
you can apply it and the underlying idea
is for me again looks quite simple so
suppose you have a function that
transforms input input to output and it
has some apparent some parameter suppose
it's this function can be split it into
two sub functions so suppose it's
iterative and suppose also that the
first part of the transformation uses
say the first half of the parameter and
the second part of the transformation
uses all the second part of the
parameter and given an input ended
output you are asked to find the
parameter value so what we are going to
do you will just simply split the
parameter into two parts the first one
as you assume is used only in the first
answer in the first half of the
transformation the second one used only
in the second part and for each possible
value of the first parameter you compute
the function up to the middle you take
an output and inverse in the function
you compute again the same state for all
possible values of the second half of
the parameter of parameter two and you
are looking for a colliding pair and if
some states here collides with states
from that first computation which means
that you get a well transformation from
input to output and a combination of
this parameter one and parameter two
values he'll do a well it value of the
full parameter so if a parameter has n
bits then this attack finds value in
with the complexity to the number two
that's true some and that's true for day
one input/output pair but if you have
two input output pairs then you can run
this attacks in parallel and you just
have more conditions in the middle and
we just increase in the number of input
out the pair's it's very unlikely that
the key that you find is not legitimate
and even if you have only a single pair
you greatly reduce the size of the
number of keys candidate a kind of we
can reformulate this property as follows
there are two to the N possible
parameters and time able to enumerate
all these parameters as pairs and the
first element of a pair can get two to
the N over two values and the second
tournament also get to the N over two
values so what I am able to do I am able
to cover two today and parameters with
just two to them over two computations
and which means that I can test many
parameters we're much faster than
testing them one by one with the kind of
square root advantage here and this idea
is this the same idea is in the attack
on a es so we will be able to enumerate
many keys with much smaller number of
computations and from that we get an
advantage
an application to this principle is an
attack on unfamous that will des so
double des has sixty four-bit state and
just 256-bit keys which are used to
intercept occurs in the vacations of
irregular deaths suppose you have two
plaintext and ciphertext pairs under a
secret key then you recover that key as
follows following the simple at MIT in
the middle framework you just consider
all possible first keys and compute the
middle state you as des can be inverted
to you compute the middle state for all
possible second keys and imagine a pair
Museum a candidate key and for two
plaintext ciphertext player it's very
likely that this candidate key is the
secret key the compact stylistic is only
two 256 which is of course much smaller
than just exhaustive search for all
possible 112 be the same principle well
thus attack appeared more than 30 years
ago but it can be the main principle is
reused in our attacks and AES well it's
not simple to use it because by default
this kind of attacks can cover only say
one third to five years or so that's why
they were never explored other deeply
the question was how to extend them
extend the range of this attack to cover
the remaining AES round and that was
done with the construction that we call
the big-league someone even told me that
an japanese big leagues mean something
sorry
it didn't work on AES so simply because
the es key cannot be splitted so simply
yeah due to the key expansion it was not
possible to separate what not clear how
to separate AES key into independent
parts of key material okay so what we
decided to do someone said that it's not
like happiness I always thought that
once at some crypt a coffee break okay
so the idea of a big reconstruction is
again as in the meat in the middle
attack to enumerate more keys with fewer
states or computations so that you can
compute less and still test in try more
keys in this example I suppose that I
want to test say nine keys which form a
matrix 3x3 and I construct something
looks like be party graph with three
states on the Left three states on the
right this is a part of a cipher so that
for each key from the metrics there
exists a transformation from one state
to a ciphertext following this formula
so in this structure nine keys are
described
or enumerated with three states and
three ciphertext and assuming you can
find this construction for larger
constructions for a large number of keys
for reasonably many C rounds of AES then
the full attack looks as follows
you split a cipher into three parts for
the last part you construct this
complicated B click with many keys but
you our assumption is you can do it
easily for the remaining parts which for
AES is only three or four rounds that is
the length that was possible that was
kind of breakable but meet in the middle
at X but this attacks were not popular
because it's only three or four rounds
so in the left part above the H and
green rectangles we use a simple Midna
middle attacks the key element is that I
enumerate the keys in the way that if I
can run omitting the middle attack in
this part that then from one state I am
allowed to you to make only one
computation and from the ciphertext if
they I ask for the decryption
I also need only one computation in one
direction so the idea is similar to meet
the middle attacks so from the states in
a B click i compute backward some middle
state from the ciphertext of a B click I
ask for the decryption and compute some
middle States and the matching pair
yields my candidate key there exist more
or less convincing argument that the
attack works because if I assume that
some key is the right key the key of my
matrix which I used in the Big Lick
instruction in the right key then if i
trace the encryption of a plaintext on
those keys then I will see that it will
follow exactly the pattern of my meet in
the middle attack and following the big
thick construction I'm and the big leak
instruction helps me to
detect that this is the right so
summarizing the Bickley construction
helps me to test many keys with smaller
more ties complexity and it allows me to
run missing the middle attacks on much
smaller rounds that is required for that
number of runs that was possible
originally so originally it was possible
to animate the middle attacks on three
or four rounds of AES and we found how
to construct a B click for the Romanian
say four rounds that gave us a new
attack the problem with attack on es 28
was as follows it was rather easy to
construct a small B click for mini
rounds and large B Creek which gives a
larger advantage over brute force for
smaller number of France and originally
the very first attack we got it didn't
cover the full years and it had very
small advantage over brute force so the
question was is it possible to combine
this ideas to get something on the full
AES and the idea was to admit explicitly
that we do a bit of exhaustive search of
keys in a very small portion of the
cipher so for AES 192 the number of
pression we do for each key is only
one-fifth of a cipher which means
essentially that we can test all a es
192 keys 5 times as fast as by
exhaustive search that was a kind of
cheating but before it was well
generally people didn't complain that
well they it was generally admitted that
if an attack has an advantage of say
five six times over brute force that
they say well it attack and yeah but by
almost any formal definition of an
attack this is a way that attack
we've contributed the nature of previous
attacks because they tried to recover a
key in a very complicated way and never
had kind of portions of exhaustive
search so we just decided to use this
portions of exhaustive search explicitly
and this yielded us disadvantage over
brute force so this is the summary of
our results and they mean that we
decreased the security level of AES two
to three bit only but that was the first
result on the full yes versions the
question of course appeared is this an
attack or is it an optimization of
exhaustive search and well a simple
answer that for practical purpose it
doesn't matter so if you are able to
recover a key find five times faster
than before
it does matter how how how you can do it
from a more smarter search or from an
attack or from some kind of IED no sets
over or whatever it doesn't matter so if
you are able to recover key faster than
needed then you succeed and we as we
have arguments that if there appears in
future and adversary with this
computational power it will he will
choose our method over a simple
exhaustive search so which means that by
many arguments this should be considered
an attack but this definitely should not
be considered as a threat and probably
this shouldn't be considered this
doesn't have any practical implication
because the fact that you do even a
small portion of a cipher for each key
this essentially gives you a lower bound
on the complexity of your attack and
this lower bound can be beaten so if you
consider even a single bit operation for
each key this is still much
more than you can do on the computer
with the computational power of the
earth
because we had have a kind of stronger
claim that if an attacker would want to
optimize an exhaustive search in some
way this is the smartest way he can
choose because it's in several steps
it's very simple it's very similar sorry
to the exhaustive search in particular
steps and we just show how to shave off
a large portion of a cipher so instead
of exhaustive search over ten rounds of
AES we propose to exhaustively search on
two rounds of AES and of course it's
appealing this pretty much the same
operations effort as the diversity will
choose for exhaustive search over the
keys so claiming that we have basically
the same prayer and we our attacks are
deterministic so we can prove that if
that any key will be found so there is
basically little reason to prefer
exhaustive search to our attack and our
attacks can be also traded for a
different amount of data so there is
different trade-offs so this optimized
version requires larger data but almost
any number of plaintext and cipher texts
can be used in this attack yes
so it's possible to have a a argument
that it's something if you're if your
assumptions about distribution of this
intermediate well I would say that we
did not rely on any distribution
properties in the middle we only claim
that and we can prove it that if the
well our attack can be seen as testing
several assistant keys and groups we
take a group of 256 bit key but test it
very fast we take another group attested
very fast and so on and so forth and for
each group we can prove that if a secret
key is among this group then it will be
found with our procedure doesn't matter
what the distribution is it will be
found dancer-ly
sorry no I really feel that there is no
big room for this attack so in the with
the idea that you do some portion of
exhaustive search you can go really far
and so far there is no clue how to avoid
this our so-called big leagues only
large big sticks give you a reasonable
advantage and they are very difficult to
construct four more rounds that's why
okay so that was the summary of attacks
on the ears I will cover now the attacks
on shot too and then give my views on
the perspectives of both standards so
when speaking about hash functions I
talked about collision to preimage
resistance and as I said that shuttle
design was so was very difficult to
analyze and collision most of the
collision search technique were found to
be inapplicable to shut to or found
working for only few rounds for example
I remind you that the chateaux sha-256
has 64 rounds and only recently a 27
round collision was found for share 256
and it was found on a PC and there was
no clue how to expand this attack on
more rounds there were no idea how to
design a theoretical but not practical
attack with complex to say to to the 100
for morons so what people are able to do
yes yes it's not yes
okay so for collision attacks the
situation is very difficult and so far
on the ad-hoc methods which require lots
of programming and which are very
difficult to when for presented papers
and so on for pretty much attacks the
station is a bit different and the best
preimage attacks in terms of breaking
the number of run the maximum number of
France is a version of our picnic attack
that was original article the first
picnic attack a Puritan before the yes
attack was designed but the key property
is despite we didn't use any exhaustive
search tricks the complexity of a
pre-image search is very close to 256
fewer rounds have larger advantage over
brute force but still not much
and this 46 rounds is only 2/3 of a hash
function we have complexity very close
to the brute force how to treat this
situation and should we expect that more
rounds can be broken with the similar
techniques I will show you shortly now
I'll show my favorite pictures
I could for a yes there appeared many
techniques and in this hundreds of
papers that are written on the yes there
were designed new methods improvements
to this methods small tricks and
improvements for those improvements and
so on and so forth but the overall
result for aes-128 and did security
level is here and I wouldn't say that
it makes the station very different to
what we had 15 years ago when es was
designed so when it was designed there
was almost no practical six rounds
attack and all the attacks for seven
rounds and higher were not possible over
the years there appeared to be better
sixth round attack a significantly
better well for practical terms but all
the attacks in the last thousands of
papers deals with improvements in this
area over to the 100 and here is our
attack and the summary is all this
attack including our attack provides a
very high theoretical value but for
security level obvious one - indeed they
have really small impact this is good
this is actually what we aimed for to
prove that even the best techniques
doesn't do not decrease the security
level of AES and it is still secure
yeah yeah somewhere around was a bit
improved and yeah well this results were
indeed sorry yes okay so and from this
graphic for me it's very hard to make
meaningful prediction about the future
of yes and but for I would personally
say that over the future 10 years if we
expect even the same progress with well
suppose this green line can be moved to
the right for the same distance this
still does wouldn't give you an attack
and meaningful attack on turnarounds and
the practical attacks well what is the
distance if I have passed for practical
attacks if you select say Toto 70 as
more or less practical value which is
feasible safe governments then the step
over 15 years is less than around if you
extrapolate this then me yes could be
considered secure for the future 30
years at least for Chateau citation is
similar
starting with four collision attacks
well there were only a few collision
attacks on sha-256 but still we are
quite far from doing something on 64
rounds so the distance that have passed
he is indeed 11 rounds from 16 to 27 and
over 8 years or so in total to probably
take us 20 30 more years to make sense
and meaningful for 64 rounds of sha-256
that's per collision resistance that's
probably more interesting because most
of the numbers here are within some
meaningful range for preimage resistance
all the numbers are purely theoretical
here they increase and I'm not aware of
any preimage attack on sha-256 we have
the reasonable number of France which is
below 2 to 128 for 16 rounds you
probably can do that the problem is that
your Europe the in each county update
one with one word of message to update
two words of the state so it's not
completely trivial to use this Porsche
one year Porsche one 16 hours can do
simply but Porsche to do that simple and
the progress we have seen again over
years this it can be extrapolated that's
true and probably for in the law in the
future 10 years we will see some attacks
in this range about around 2 to 200 or
so on the full shell 256 but unless
there will be a progress there unless
there is a progress in practical
preimage attacks there is no practical
threat and
all they're pretty much all these dozen
of premature text appeared recently
ninety-five percent of them deal with
are beyond the birthday bond have
complex to larger than two to the N over
two because of the of their meet in the
middle nature and the prospects for
cryptanalysts are on the one hand said
because it will probably very difficult
to find some practical attack on either
standard on the other hand there is much
room for improvement and many more
techniques can be designed and used on
sure 256 and yes my summary Oh on the
attacks on these two standards is that
AAS is still very secure I have several
ideas well it's natural to ask for
better properties found in the fully in
AES on more rounds or better meet the
middle attacks but still is very secure
and for chateau we'll probably need
better understanding of its elements of
the modeler Edition which is used
non-linear adjust that are used and so
on and from this two plots my personal
time is that probably with we are not in
big need on or in Shafi if this from the
practical point of view
thank you for attention eh yeah well for
the Secor idea that was designed over 20
years ago we have better attacks well on
the full version we have a bit larger
advantage about produced version with
the B click we can do much better so
it's advantage up to the 20 or so
possibly well I think it's all
convertible to the ciphers vulnerable to
meet in the middle attacks you probably
can just sound can make sometimes
resistant to main tomainia attacks but
vulnerable to meet the middle yeah
that's it oh good exercise but a very
important I would stress that all
meet-in-the-middle checks have lower
bound on the complexity and that's the
square root of the parameter length your
attack if you take 128-bit key you can
be faster than 2064 if you consider
premature attacks on 256 bit digest you
can't be better than 2 to 128 well this
is not necessary to make a toy cipher
well to demonstrate that we can test
keys faster than an exhaustive search we
can take just a smaller subset of AES
keys and see and they must say that we
can tell them faster that's purely
possible
well as the cypher we are taking is
still secure then it's probably was a
good design
well Oh only for most of the Kshatriya
candidates they're not working at all
because they have different structure
this are called white pipe design the
well they do not work but the
consequence of the white pipe design is
that you sacrifice significant amount of
speed to eat and most of the white pipe
sha-3 candidates are not even faster
than chateau in the published version
it's from 2 to the 42 to the 80 but it
can be really downgraded with only a
small penalty in the time complexity so
the minute this pretty much the same can
be with to the a to the 16 later chosen
data so it's only an exercise really I
expect some people find low data
complexity attacks on the years but it's
just a matter of technical work this
methods are very suitable for trade and
data for complexity
yeah well for example the scheme design
is quite natural it's very suitable for
this type of attacks but for collision
and preimage resistance we are still
well overall force a three candidates
collision premature texts can cover
about one-third of the design so if you
have 12 rounds and four rounds can be
are well double for collision of
primatech theoretically and first gain
it's about the same situation but with
this kind of attacks for other shuttle
candidates again one third of them is
vulnerable but for different kinds of
attacks so these attacks do not give
much higher adventure in the sense